okay so he he's uh pushy but I'm I'm in
his Center so when I uh I'm gonna uh
affect my elbow it'll affect his elbow
but it'll affect his Center okay so I'm
just here you see and you can see his
energy is going that way
So to that I add my weight ship well
he's going around I just keep the arm
going around
okay so pay attention
foreign
[Music]
comes around and then there's a natural
place where his balance will be
well so you don't want to cut down
it'll keep him going
your time I can do that same angle for
example but I'm pulling it you see
don't just incrementally boom bringing
them in
[Music]
of course if you wanted to stop his feet
you could stop
if you want
you want it we're just working on this
connection
so it it is important that he is uh
establishing the initial conflict okay
but what happens sometimes is you're
just going here and you're getting out
of the way of him
for example uh I go like this do you see
that space there okay I don't want that
space okay
um so when I'm doing it
it's more
that I have an adhesion here I'm not
using his fingertips to get it and then
Aikido culture that he turns okay I I am
open your hand okay I'm working in there
that's what I'm working
so in here is my IP adhesion that's what
that's what I like
okay so to demonstrate that more uh
we'll have him pull okay he's pulling
okay and uh he's going the whole time
and I should be able to use that idea
so but it will if you're not doing it
okay so I've been this Ikea oh
[Music]
you got to tell everybody who can't sell
it
all right let's try it for a
confirmation reader